so this organization you have core is
very involved in kovat 19 you're making
sure that people can get tested not the
United States government your
organization is doing this there's
something's so crazy to me that we're
almost like a third-world country now
that that Sean Penn has to go out and do
testing for people covered 19 well
what's going on here
yeah I think it's there's a couple
answers so we all know that there have
been no federal guidelines no national
plan on this not even an attempt at lon
and so we found partners if not in
governor's we found them in mayors and
we were about to open seven sites in New
York City all it and all with the focus
being on the most marginalized
communities because these are the
communities where people are dying as we
sit here I've got about a thousand staff
nationwide running these sites and I am
someone who tends to defer to science
and what scientists tell us is that this
is a necessary thing it's and it's
happening at a time in history where you
know we're in a certain kind of social
evolution I you know we consider
ourselves a corps Pro - test protest I
would love to be able to see these
rounds and I've seen them on the streets
were around where we work and I've seen
them on television on the news there's
masses of people with a really you know
overall noble mission that as I said
earlier I think is gonna make a change
for the better
why how much more powerful a picture
that would be and how much larger
footprint they would have if they just
distanced six feet with a mask on yes
we're gonna be going into deep
Washington DC working with Mayor
Bowser's office I believe next week just
start mobile testing and protesters and
I and just hope you know whatever little
effect we can have encouragement we can
have did just
moving things in that direction I don't
sense that the protests are gonna stop
soon I think that they are a fundamental
part of us moving forward
it's an existential moment it's a if we
don't see it as that if we think that
that's a hyperbolic comment just wait
and see read a history book and it's
either gonna invigorate you or depress
you but it's not gonna leave you in a
grey zone which I think too many people
who in a comfort addicted country tend
to go to this is uh this is time to to
ring those bells so it's a shame that it
happened during a pandemic but both
testing and protesting are essentials
right now we can't lose this moment
you